そういえば同元ってなんで日本に興味を
持ったあ日本が好きになったきっかけです
かそうですね僕は実はアニメとかあいや
あの僕はどちらかと言えばドラゴンボール
が好きそうな顔してるもんね嫌いじゃない
んですけどやっぱり同義もアニメオタなん
だねですからストーリーがよければ見ます
嫌いなアニメだっていく好きな登場人物は
考えたことありませんでもCって言えばえ
なので日本に興味を持ったきっかけは
トランクスCて言えばご飯ですCて言えば
ですやっぱりおいけんちゃんお前と同じ
趣味のやついたわちょっと待ってください
やっぱりじゃありませんさっきと全然違う
ことをああ好きなジブリ映画はありません
いやあるだろうていうのはまだ見ていない
ジブリ映画がたくさんありますのでてこと
はやっぱ見てるんだねですから日本が好き
になったのはアニメじゃなかったら
JPOPだろうjpopでもありません
なんかめっちゃ夜遊び聞いてるイメージ
ある最近ブラッドボーンの音楽しか聞いて
いませんブラッドボーンあゲームですそっ
かゲームから入ったんだね話を聞いて
いただけますかスマブラで誰使うスマブ
最後にやったのは高校時代ですでもやった
んだねあ好きなドラクエはエトやったこと
ありません俺もナが大好きなんだおいけん
ちゃん早く勝手に予想するのやめてもらっ
てもいいですかえ外国人はみんなゆは何し
に日本への方にはまるわけじゃありません
あごめん別に悪気が全くないので日本人
すぐそうしますから
おいそれステレオタイプだぞそういうこと
ですあそっかそういうことかそれは悪かっ
たな大丈夫ですただし今後気をつけて
くださいねああそうするそうだ同元が日本
に興味を持ったきっかけって結局何だった
んだあ格闘技ですへえ格闘技かはいなんだ
んやっぱドラゴンボールのタ
じゃん
til